les siennes depuis plus de 30 ans
stéphanie jamin et tête de liste
d'énergie positive qui rassemble une
diversité de citoyens lors des réunions
la participation citoyenne et les coudes
sont mises en avant
une liste qui n'est pas soutenu par un
parti politique
vous avez eu l'occasion de partir à
d'autres réunions des trois autres
listes est là où elle s'est différencié
c'est qu'on avait le droit ou désaccord
stéphanie jamin souhaite une démocratie
locale plus transparente avec par
exemple 9 conseils municipaux par an au
lieu de cinq
le but instaurer un temps d'échangé
entre les cliniciens et les élus en
début de conseil
c'est quelque chose de vraiment nouveau
je trouve ça on est en train de
construire non construit pas dans la
politique on construit un peu entre amis
mais pour une ville pour tous
la proximité une des valeurs de cette
liste stéphanie jamin et les
participants préparent leur planning
d'actions
oui mais ça se prépare quand même leur
objectif aller à la rencontre des clés
siens du porte à porte en plusieurs
groupes pour aller présenter notre
programme et nos premières propositions
entre les siens nous avons également
prévu d'organiser des balades kretiennes
qui se déroule généralement sur des
moments
de tant de villes etc les siens nous
allons à la rencontre nous allons
l'or aussi leur exposer nos propositions
mais également écouter quels sont leurs
besoins
nous avons prévu des distribution dans
les boîtes aux lettres de manière
classique
une réunion publique est organisée à 10h
le samedi 29 février à l'école on répond
des clayes-sous-bois